( intro music )
In 2013, I was asked to cover
breast cancer in Uganda.
Breast cancer has less than
a handful of oncologists
in the whole country.
A woman who has
breast cancer
thinks of it as a
death sentence.
Most of the resources in
Uganda went to HIV-AIDS.
So cancer is something that is
sort of just seen as a curse.
This is Mary
she had been living with
tumors for several years
but didn't want to tell
anyone, she was ashamed.
There was a team of American
doctors from Seattle
who went to try and bring
ultrasound technology
to detect tumors early.
When she took off her
shirt, this is what we saw
and they did a biopsy on Mary
and it turned out the
cancer was very localized.
and she was able to get a
mastectomy and survived.
This is Jolly and her husband.
She had gotten a
mastectomy a year before
and did not follow up, and
I spent five days with her
until she died.
And this is her daughter seeing
her mother in the casket.
She didn't even know her
mother had passed away.
She just got a call and was
pulled out of boarding school
and when she came into the
truck, they just opened the lid
and... there was her mother.
And I was crying so hard
when I took this picture
it's completely out of focus.
And that's Jolly's bed about
half an hour after she died.
They're cleaning it and getting
ready for another woman.
And this is, there is
one radiation machine
that serves four countries.
It works 24 hours a day.
This is Jessy, she was trying
to get chemotherapy.
She had two sons and was
determined to stay alive.
But she didn't have $10
to take the bus back home
to see her children in
between chemo treatments
so she slept outside of the
hospital for two months.
She had to change her
own bandages every day
because there was no one
available to do that.
This is her finally
getting chemo
and she is leaving the hospital
to go see her children.
This is her on the bus-ride back
and her sister washing
her when she gets home.
And this is her
with her children.
And Jessy died about six
months after that story.